salut aujourd'hui je suis avec monsieur
jérémie credeville et bonjour alias j'ai
c'est le plus beau geste que j'ai eues
en 53 vidéo les mecs
merci on sort du plateau des comics dont
fait partie jérémy crédible c'est aux
blancs manteaux et on en profite pour
faire une vidéo parce que ce sera la
vidéo de demain je la mettrais 7 heures
demain monsieur brice je suis en flux
tendu là j'ai ce soir tu as fait de
l'impro j'ai trouvé ça super cool
c'était décidé d'ailleurs cueillis fait
pas d'un pronom son spectacle mais ce
mec là vient de l'impôt en fait je me
suis dit on reprend le thème de la pro
pour cette vidéo j'aimerais que tu
choisisses soi-même dans ta tête deux
mots comme couton quand toi tu demandes
aux gens des mots qui sait pour reporter
les impôts qui choisit de mots dans ta
tête tu me le dis pas d'accord ok tu les
as en fait je les ai en tête ne peut pas
les connaître mais non on est d accord
avec toi et je vais te demander de faire
une impro avec ces mots là ok là pour
l'instant je n'ai pas dit pourquoi tu
veux que les données c'était pour re
pourquoi tu te facilite toi même la
tâche mais je vais devoir refaire une
impro avec les moquettes a choisi et que
je ne connais pas et du coup mon but à
moi ma mission mon job c'est de
retrouver quel mot tu place quels mots
tu t'es imposé pour qu'on ait un projet
d'accord donc si lente at elle choisi
soleil et nuages mais quand on est pro
tu vas aller dire à un moment donné
elles n'ont ramené à oui c'est soleil et
nuages c'est le mot de son impôt en
titre mais pour me piéger n'hésite pas
en mettre plein peut-être les mots
classique qu'on te donne dans les
approches salon donne toujours
anticonstitutionnellement oued et c'est
pas mon maître plein pour mon brouillée
c'est parti on stocke le coup ce film là
ça film là et si on on
je suis complètement bourrel j'appelle
un über application bieber a aucune
voiture n'est disponible
comment vais je faire je devais pas le
pen beach il faut peut-être en citer
trois
où va prévenir votre chauffeur arrive
dans quelques minutes et genia lui
arrive
bonjour monsieur vous êtes bourrés oui
vous le fait vachement bien merci
beaucoup
esii montée le mans mentale avant non on
n'est pas chez itg par accor tout le
monde derrière c'est génial vous avez
une musique préférée aux non mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez mais pas demander
l'adresse et il fallait à dire bombe à
ce moment là en taxi oublier non la
tâche une impro bah oui moi je suis
c'est des impros cent des bus ont chuté
j'ai dit c'est que j'étais bon enfant
enfin presque parce que parce que moi
j'ai bien mangé ça dépend des mots on va
juger c'est vraiment moi il ya un mot
que je pense avoir chopé mais du coup je
croyais que ça allait continuer qu'il y
avait un deuxième boum du collège je les
écris dû prendre un bloc notes je vais
les écrire là et puis comme ça il le
voit ici avec la caméra le suspense
busch pilote bon pour moi c'est sûr
c'est celui 6 l'écrivent bien ici tac je
suis je et alors du coup faut que j'en
trouve un deuxième
hu et je dirais cette question j'ai pas
allez vous le voyez je vous le fais voir
là je vous fait voir la rapidement en
garde et douala comme ça c'est sous la
trappe à vue alors je vois alors un tous
les genevois n'ont surtout pas rare de
voir la belle diversion veto de la
commission
ok vous l'avez bien vu vous l'avez vu
aussi sur cette caméra est ce que tu
peux venir
quels sont les mots que ta place et
danton a provoqué limite imposée à
placer dedans il y avait un voiture il y
avait blues
j'avais une blouse le deuxième n'était
pas bien sûr de l'avoir mais je les lui
jalousent et voiture blue cet éclair
voitures gt passe joli village érigé sur
l'île de leurs noms mais oui mais voilà
voilà
eh bah écoute bravo mais bravo à toi
mais retenons c'est vrai plus à abbas à
lula oui je dis que je suis sur le cul
ah oui avec d'autres comme des théâtres
du coup je comptais merci manger aller
voir son spectacle qu'il est vraiment
mortel tu joues du mercredi au samedi
aux blancs manteaux
voilà les mercredi 7 à 21h et du jeudi
au samedi à 19h30 c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu compliqué du mercredi au
samedi
merci beaucoup abonnez-vous à la chaîne
c'est très important rendez vous ce soir
à 20 heures au grand point virgule pour
le plateau hallucination collective et
autres illusions et rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao